[plane landing]
[suspenseful music]
OFFICER MARRERO: We're going
to run all these boxes.
Through the mail facility,
we get narcotics every day.
You name it, we've
seen it loaded.
Sneakers, coffee beans,
radios, hard drives,
electronic equipment.
Nothing surprises us anymore.
It's like, every day
you get something new.
[suspenseful music]
This one was a negative.
Definitely not narcotics.
[suspenseful music]
That doesn't look good.
OFFICER MARRERO (VOICEOVER):
And it says, sporting
goods equipment and two fans.
I don't see the
reason to send fans.
They got them everywhere.
This package is coming
from a source country,
Trinidad and Tobago,
and it's going
to a demand country, Australia.
The value is very high over
there for any type of narcotic.
Something doesn't look right.
This seems like cheap
plastic, but in the image
it looks too thick.
The only way to really look
if you don't like the image--
take a quick peek inside.
[intense music]
See that, right there?
That's not supposed to be there.
That's why it looks thicker
in the X-ray machine.
They usually glue them in.
And they're not hard to pop off.
Try to see if we can peel
back a little bit of it,
so we can see what's under it.
And whatever it is, it's
wrapped in aluminum foil.
See?
It's loaded.
You can see that it's white.
I'll test it real quick.
We should have green
with some pink above it.
It's hard to see
but, it's there.
It's positive.
It's cocaine.
We have 806.4 grams.
[intense music]
I can tell you what it's
going to go for now-- nothing.
One for the good guys.